今天咱们不聊家长里短，
不聊感情纠纷，
今天龙飞给大家推荐一本救命的书，
不是噱头，
这本书是正经的乳腺科的医生是教授级别的，
博士生导师级别的医生写的一本书。
每一个女生，
不管你现在是十几岁、
二十几岁、
三十几岁、
四十几岁，
还是五十几岁，
你都一定要去看，
因为你错过这次机会，
可能就错过了了解自己身体的一次机会，
如果因为这次的错过导致什么严重的后果，
就会追悔莫及。
我先问你几个问题，
你看你知不道答案，
再决定你要不要学习。
首先，
第一你知不知道新生儿刚出生的几天，
他也会胀奶的，
如果你处理的不当的话，
孩子会特别遭罪的，
无论男宝还是女宝。
第2个问题是你怎么判断孩子她的乳房的发育是正常的，
他有没有性早熟的迹象？
第3个问题，
你在少女时代的时候有没有经历过困扰？
比如说左边和右边的胸形状大小不一样，
你有没有非常焦虑过？
再有，
你知道乳房最害怕我们生活当中的一些习惯呢？
有了孩子需要哺乳的妈妈们知不知道如何防止乳房下垂呢？
更重要的是知不知道怎么？
啊，
避免乳腺炎呀，
再有，
我们人到中年呢，
我的乳腺结节是怎么来的？
乳腺癌又最容易瞄准哪些人呢？
请问这些问题如果你自己不操心，
谁会关心你呢？
所以今天我必须把这本书焊死在你的收藏夹里。
作者史晓光教授一辈子研究乳腺健康，
救过无数女生的命。
他写这本书绝对不是那些晦涩难懂的专业词汇，
而是最平实的大白话，
最朴实的干货，
小学毕业就能看得懂的表达。
因为我的女粉是占90%的，
我光推荐这本书都是在攒。
因为乳腺的健康真的不能等，
不能拖，
不要寄希望于别人会来关心你，
好多姐妹就是因为平时自己不注意，
不懂，
等到发现问题的时候已经晚了，
轻则需要调理，
重则需要割除，
到时候再后悔真的没用。
这本书不是你看完就完事儿了，
是你要真正开始了解自己的身体，
要学会自查，
学会预防，
在问题还小的时候积极的去解决它，
不要被误导，
也不要被焦虑裹挟。
不管你是年轻的女孩子，
还是已经当了妈妈，
不管你现在是不是有乳腺方面的问题，
你一定要先去学习它好吗？
几个小时就能看完，
看完可能就会避开一些健康陷阱，
在关键的时刻救你一命。
除非我从来不会乱推荐书，
能让我反复逼着你们去看的，
一定是能帮到你们的东西，
这本书没有多余的废话，
全是能用到的知识，
错过这本书，
可能就会错过一次机会，
去了解自己，
拯救自己。